linda riou s'est fait poser des implants
mammaires en 1998 récemment ses douleurs
au sein longtemps inquiété les implants
textures et sont liées au lymphome
anaplasique à grandes cellules un cancer
rare mais grave jeu comme dans l'inconnu
parce que je sais pas ce que j'ai comme
un pain en mai dernier
santé canada a interdit la vente d un
plan bio celle d'allergan le principal
fournisseur des prothèses textures et au
pays
linda riou a tout fait pour savoir si
c'est ce type d'implant qu'on lui a posé
à la clinique privée où on l'a opéré
mais son dossier médical a été détruit
quand son chirurgien est parti à la
retraite sa panda le veut pas détruire
un dossier médical
la problématique à l'heure actuelle et
le fait qu'on a tellement de membres de
notre gros qui ont aucune des casquettes
et leur internement
au québec la conservation obligatoire
des dossiers médicaux et de cinq ans une
des raisons c'était parce que les
médecins avaient plus de place pour
mettre leurs dossiers où la technologie
tout à fait d'accord avec vous le
collège des médecins dit attendre depuis
longtemps la réponse de l'office des
professions du québec à sa demande de
aussi la norme à 10 ans c'est la
province qui est la plus courte durée de
conservation des dossiers au canada ça
fait longtemps qu'on demande que tout
prothèse que ce soit une prothèse
mammaire une prothèse georges une
prothèse de genou
peace maker soit inscrit dans un
registre c'est au niveau privé on est
capable de mettre sur pied des registres
de chacune des pièces de mon automobile
comment ça se fait qu'on parle d'êtres
humains d'un plat médicaux lorsqu'il ya
un rappel sur un produit implantées dans
le corps humain
on ne reçoivent pas un coup de fil ou
une carte dans notre boîte à lettres
pour être en paix avec moi même pour peu
inquiet mais je vais les faire enlever
les hôpitaux concerne les informations
concernant les implants donc récemment
près de 7500 québécoise opéré à
l'hôpital pour une reconstruction
mammaire ont reçu un avis au sujet des
implants texture est par contre de
nombreuses femmes opérées en clinique
privée
elles ne savent toujours pas ce qu'elles
ont sous la peau ici esther normand
radio canada montréal